everybody's gonna throw us in the trash
I think that's good I know what's up and
then we have in this locker room and
quite frankly I don't really give a damn
what happens on the outside I know how
we're gonna react I know what we're
gonna do we're gonna bounce back and we
got a Monday night game coming up so we
don't really care
Baker Mayfield look I like the fact that
he's trying to do what he can to
motivate his team after losing by 30
points at home to start the season but
here's the bottom line you lost at home
by 30 points to start the season right
people are gonna throw trash on you
because it was a trash performance you
put trash on the field people are gonna
put trash on top of it so instead of
worrying about what people are gonna say
outside of the organization and I know
that Baker Mayfield is trying to
motivate his guys and trying to find
something to rally around they they
looked horrible
they deserve all the criticism they get
Chris well yeah I mean we we've you know
like Delanie Walker said in our little
opening there before we came on radio I
mean if you want to crown him go ahead
and crown him you're right I mean a lot
of us have crowned them because of the
sexiness of their roster and we all love
Baker Mayfield and Jarvis Landry and
Odell Beckham jr. and it just looks cool
and we see talent on the demons inside
of the ball all right so it was it was a
bad loss we know that but he's they're
gonna take positives I mean the game was
1513 late in the third quarter the way
they're gonna look at that and go okay
now what did we do when they're gonna go
back and look at it and Baker Mayfield
is gonna realize wow I made some throws
and some plays that I usually don't make
that was a big issue they shot
themselves in the foot a number of times
yesterday protection was an issue that
was the first part of the downfall and
the offensive line was a big question
mark for this team to begin with and
then Greg Greg Robinson gets kicked out
of the game and if you're watching this
play on TV Cameron Waitkus is safety and
certainly hurts Baker Mayfield elbow to
a degree right Mike we saw that live
action and there was just a number of
errant missed throws from that point on
where we just haven't seen Baker
Mayfield missed the target by the margin
he missed a few times yesterday yeah I
remember in that preseason game where we
last saw Baker Mayfield he didn't look
sharp sigh Wow a little
Yeah right Jaden if just right to hit
everybody yesterday yeah and the Titans
knew that that gunslinger mentality
would create opportunities for them
Kevin Baier the Titans safety told me
after the game that that they they
expected this and that Dean Pease the
defense coordinator through every
coverage in the book at Baker Mayfield
so he had to deal with everything and
they got three interceptions all in the
fourth quarter
Kevin buyer told me we could add five
yesterday yeah and they win by 30 points
and look a close game can quickly become
a blowout when you get desperate and
when you try to press right when your
mistake and then the only source of ball
in the window fourteen becomes 21 that's
a blow up right and then that's kind of
what happened yeah you know even early
on you know the the Browns went right
down the field early on in the game we
said oh gosh this is what we all thought
it would look like this looks amazing
you know and then they went through a
stale point of you know late first
quarter second quarter even early third
quarter but of one of the big issues
that kept hurting them more than
anything in the offensive side of the
ball we talked about protection all that
but the penalties I mean what was it a
hundred and eighty something yards of
penalties yesterday penalties the most
the Browns have had since 1951 so there
was a number of plays were first down we
went oh it's second and two off penalty
it's first and 20 I mean there was a lot
of that yesterday where they put
themselves in a hole before drives even
started and and of course caught up to
them and and I got to give able and Dean
pees a lot of credit for what they did
key factor in all of this yeah Freddie
kitchens yeah new head coach wasn't
interim head coach last year was just
interim offensive coordinator right got
promoted to head coach a year ago we
would not have pegged this guy as being
an NFL head coach and some I want to get
your take on this I talked about this
earlier on the radio side when I saw his
arrival interview yesterday with Steve
why she of NFL Network I was like
where's Freddie kitchens completely
clean shaven right like like his edge
was gone like like just you know the the
Matt naggy be you right don't shave
right be who you are you're dog pound
hoodie don't change don't act like the
way you think a head coach should act
yeah I feel like that's that the day a
guy who hasn't been groomed to be a head
coach right I didn't expect to be a head
coach
I think there's a danger that you're
gonna act the way you think a head coach
should act instead of being who you are
cuz that's what got you to where you are
and the challenge now is gonna be as he
rolls out of it he's not number one he's
not gonna want to get out of bed right
right right and and number two how do
you put this debacle behind you and
focus on getting this team ready for the
Jets how do you say the right things at
the right times do the right things make
the right decisions make the right plans
and this guy's never done it before yeah
he's never coached before no coach and
he lost his first game by 30 points at
home how do you prevent this from
becoming an avalanche yeah well I do
think they have the right people in that
locker room and on that coaching staff I
mean Freddie kitchens as a fighter Steve
Wilkes on the defensive side of the ball
another guy's been around the NFL for a
long time so I think he's gonna be there
you know cooler heads will prevail here
in in Cleveland Baker Mayfield
tremendous leader all of that I like
your point about Freddie kitchens though
Mike I think that is something real you
know sometimes you know Freddie kitchens
I'm still a believer in him and what he
can do they're gonna have to clean up
some things that they messed up
yesterday certainly but yes be true to
yourself
especially in Cleveland you can get away
with that rugged look and you're right I
think coaches get a little bit like oh
this is the way I should look and it's
not necessarily because they wanna do
but they think their owner might like it
you know their family at home who's
watching oh let me impress mom look at
my suit and tie and I'm all clean shaven
but then I you know we turn on the
Pittsburgh Patriots game last night and
there's Bill Belichick in his pregame
press do you know interview with Liam
and he's got a cutoff sleeve and he
doesn't care about his hair and it just
you know just not that pretty looking
but the results speak for themselves so
I'm with you be true to yourself Freddie
yeah and and I think it's really gonna
be a huge test pride the next two games
for the Cleveland Browns are in
primetime Jets Rams right right Monday
night against the Jets in New York and
then Sunday night at home on and be
short we cool yeah so they got some work
cut out but and you know and and it got
ugly yesterday yes the heads were booing
them off the field by halftime and for
his jubilant as everyone was to have it
turn that way see that that's that I
felt so bad for Cleveland they're
getting the downside of being regarded
as a good team without ever doing
anything
to earn that that praise in that statue
everything negative that goes along with
it because teams are gonna want to beat
them they're gonna be fired up but you
know last year it's just the Browns now
oh-ho the Browns all that hype let's go
knock them down another peg and this
could get out of control very quickly
for the the Cleveland Browns and you
know you know hey they got a week to
turn it around they get that one extra
day and I'm sure they'll try to make the
most of it and get their their stuff
together next Monday night against the
Jets and the Jets will have every reason
to try to you know get the bad taste out
of the mouth and what happened on Sunday
against the bills
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports